Wah wah.
All aboard!
Hello everybody.
I look a little dark, huh?
I'm trying something new today.
I'm trying a more atmospheric...
vibe.
Trying a more...
atmosphere.
Trying a more atmospheric vibe.
Hello, hello, hello.
You alright?
I'm trying to think.
Anyways, welcome back to Jurassic World.
Yippee!
I've been wanting to play this game...
for...
so long.
We're off to Cap'n...
Well, let's see how this works.
Oh, I'm darker.
Let's see.
See?
It kind of works.
One year!
Wah wah wah.
Wishing I was fishing.
Thank you for one year!
So...
This music, I can't think over it.
I...
Someone told me...
last time.
They were like, I think you should do the icy area because...
you can beat the game and forget about the icy area.
And I was like, I paid for that!
I paid for that, so...
What is the one year badge?
That's a great question, Mr. YumYum.
Let me show you.
Hold on, where do I have it saved?
Oh, I have it saved here.
Here!
If you have the one year Mamboo badge...
you are officially...
the Jorker.
Number one.
We do...
Well, I don't live.
I exist.
Technically.
In a society.
Oh man, I can't wait.
Yeah, you too!
You can beat the Jorker.
I don't remember why Snake is there.
Why did I include him?
Probably because I love him.
So, yeah.
I'm a what now?
Oh, yeah.
Congratulations.
So, I think what I want to do is rest.
And then I think what I want to do is go to the icy area.
I think.
Is what I want to do.
And see what we can do...
in the ice.
He was number one.
Thank you guys!
Wow, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Really appreciate all the...
All the 12 monthers.
Captain Minton, huh?
Or the moon.
Otherwise, I don't even...
I don't remember what we did last time.
So, we're just gonna...
Let's go figure it out.
This game has so much going on.
I always have to...
Remind myself what we're doing.
Wait.
Oh, I just need to go down.
Wait, what is this?
Why is there a big old white spot on my...
It's Jork.
It's Jork!
Jork!
I think last game was Mother Base Upgrades.
Hmm.
Bald.
Why is it bald there?
Probably one of the rigged boxes.
Maybe.
That's so...
Peculiar.
Okay, we need to go south.
How would you feel about someone getting a tattoo?
Inspired by me?
That's a little permanent though.
If you cut off your arm...
Or wherever you got it...
Then...
You could forget.
13 more days till I'm a Jorker.
Don't cry!
I'll reach the Jork point someday.
I believe in you!
Laser.
That's how you choose to take off your arm?
With a laser?
Oh, why do I not have my...
Hold on.
No, just kidding.
My trawl net.
Oh, we have the siphon trawl.
I messed up.
It's fine.
We can siphon trawl here, I guess.
Laser.
The laser explodes the tattoo.
They mean the tattoo.
Yeah, that's what I was talking about also.
Oh, we're red!
How do you guys... How do we feel in the atmosphere?
Lighting.
It's a little different from normal.
But I felt like this is the type of game for it, no?
Don't run into the...
Are we gooping?
Just a tad.
I'm gonna go sleep in there anyway, so...
Collecting some goop.
Sleep in the goop?
What would we wake up with, I wonder.
I feel like we'd wake up with something horrible.
Okay.
Alright.
Goop has been...
Properly, thoroughly...
Scooped.
Let's get some... I don't remember if we needed any of this stuff either.
But...
I'll grab it.
Why not?
Oh, slopped up.
I need a shower.
Oh, oh.
The night cometh.
I'm stuck.
Why does it sound so scary?
I'm gonna have my light on.
On stream?
I don't think so.
I don't think I'll shower on stream.
I don't think I'll do that.
Aw, dang.
Guys, how do you know when something is black mold?
Is my other question.
I might have it.
In my...
In my bathroom.
How do you know when something is a black mold?
Is it humid?
Yeah.
Huh?
Oh, do I have room for all that?
I guess so.
Rub it in your face.
Okay.
Not all black mold is black mold.
I hope it's not.
I took some pictures of it today and I'm gonna say...
You know, well, it's like...
I don't know...
I mean, I know it's like an abandoned maid cafe and all that, but it's like...
I don't know.
Like...
I just...
I just hope it's not, you know, bad.
I hope they'll clean it.
My place is abandoned, but I'm still here.
We have patrons.
You guys...
Don't go into my bathroom.
Can we see the mold pictures for science?
No.
Grow white mold to cancel it out.
Then they'll have grey mold babies.
Black mold tastes like wet dirt and metal.
Really?
Wait, actually?
Okay, I'm gonna sell my fish.
Make some money.
Maybe.
I can't remember what we've been trying to do.
Let's see.
I'm just looking around at stuff.
Did I...
I can't tell if down here is another...
Engine spot or not.
It is.
Repair everything?
I don't know what we're repairing.
We're gonna take off this net.
Uninstall.
Store.
I already took the thingies out.
Took these out, so we're good.
We got two more.
One whole year of Mito Kawaii.
Wow.
You can't go?
Jersey.
Eat the mold.
Don't taste the mold.
Too late.
You're upgrading the iron rig with your rods.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
What do I wanna...
Let's see, let's replace it with our heavy duty trawl.
Wait.
Yeah!
Oh, what's this?
Oh no.
That's rot.
Wait.
Some people said to keep the rot.
Oh, soothing tea.
So many new Jorkers this stream.
I know!
What do you mean, too late?
I don't know if I told you guys this, but not too long ago...
A couple months ago, I'd say...
A pipe burst?
And a bunch of water came through my ceiling.
In my bathroom.
And...
They put a dehumidifier in my bathroom, but I think there might be mold in the walls.
So...
I thought it was just the sink.
Nah.
That was different.
Yeah.
And they keep...
They're like, hey, do you wanna renew your lease?
And I'm like, well...
I kinda wanna leave, but I don't have anywhere else to go.
I have to decide within a week.
Are you cursed?
I didn't know it.
So...
Where do I go?
I don't have anywhere to go.
I have nowhere to move to.
I can't just be like, okay, bye.
I mean, I guess I could say I'm not renewing my lease and then find a place before...
But moving is so bad.
I don't have time to move.
There's only so many abandoned maid cafes that I can go to.
Actually, pink mold tastes like strawberries.
Wait, I'm having a sense of deja vu.
That sometimes grows in my bathtub.
Moving with Mata.
Short, hairy bloke.
Thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you.
I have so many issues.
Many issues.
Let's see.
Let's do...
More fish.
I think we need that more than materials.
Okay.
Cool.
We sleep for...
It's daylight.
Let's just keep going.
I think I'm going to be a little crazy, but that's alright.
Cool.
We're heading south.
Onward!
That must be it, no?
No?
Yeah.
Oh, my thingy.
Moving sucks, but living with worsening mold isn't good for your health either.
Wait, I hope things work out.
Thanks!
Me too!
I'm a ghost though.
I don't know.
I'm more worried about the patrons.
She has no body to move in with.
Maybe the mold will...
I don't know.
Make me a little...
To prevent mold, you should leave your bathroom...
What?
Sorry, I missed it.
I leave my bathroom door open...
You!
You came out of nowhere!
Oh, my god.
That stinks!
Oh, my god!
Leaving the door open works too?
Yeah, I don't think the fan works very well in mine.
Okay, let's try and get the...
We need to break this ice.
Icy works.
To build a new icebreaker, there are the parts you need.
Oh, where do I get these?
Do you have them?
The last part meant my unit caught fire!
The fire department flooded all the way down five floors!
Luckily, I moved my stuff out the day before.
Oh, my god!
That's so scary!
What the...
Wait, how do I get this?
How do I get the icebreaker?
Plow.
I think maybe this is where I...
Um...
I'm lost.
Go out and explore.
Is it in here?
Let's check inside here.
Like these, I can't break through.
Can I fish this?
Ice.
I need ice.
Can you give us your best line you use to break ice?
Ha.
Hey.
It's a foreshore inn.
Do I need ice?
I think I need an ice rod.
Alright, let's go back.
You just gotta play it cool.
If you're just like, I'm playing it cool...
You could say, I am the ice.
Ice!
Barbed ice rod.
Maybe we'll do...
This one's cheaper.
Cause we're gonna have to get this eventually for infuse, no?
Ice, ice, baby, minky.
We know your line is Pokemon names translated.
That's not an ice... Well, yes.
Isn't that, I guess, maybe technically an icebreaker?
But like, the first thing you say...
But no, that is my thing.
But that only works in Japan.
If you're just like, hey, do you know what Pikachu is in English?
Pikachu.
Do you know what Fushigidane is in English?
Bulbasaur.
And then they're like...
And then you're like, yeah, and...
What's another one?
I
don't remember anymore.
She's fumbling.
Wait!
I forgot all of them.
Lizardon.
Oh, that's... Yeah, you could be like Charizard.
Lizard... No, opposite.
Liz... Maybe you could do this in English too, but I think everybody would think you're so lame.
I don't think they would care very much.
I don't think... They'd be like, oh, okay.
You could be like Gengar.
Gengar.
Why are some of them changed and some of them aren't?
The Pokemon Orthworm is...
Shlurm.
Hope you guys... I love the videos of like...
Of like...
The way Pokemon sound in other languages.
Like...
Install.
Like the Goldeen clip.
She's like...
Well, I don't wanna say it.
Look it up yourself.
Look up French Goldeen.
This game makes the same creaky sounds all the doors of my house makes.
Oh my gosh, it's...
Kinda creepy.
I don't even know what we're gonna do in this area.
Let's get some ice fish.
That's what we're gonna do in the area.
Wow!
Wow, it's literal ice fish.
That's a snake.
Are you sure the maids don't just think you're cute?
I don't think so.
Cause I'm not.
I'm scary spooky.
Trophy.
I'm creepy crawly.
How many ice fish are there?
Oh my god.
I think we have a problem with too many ice fish.
How many are there?
Medium stock still?
I'm gonna have the most ice fish anybody has ever obtained.
Before ever.
In the world.
There's so many.
I don't think it's possible to make them go extinct.
Uh oh.
I made them go extinct.
Kowakawa.
Shut up.
Can I get some money for this?
And they're extinct.
How much were they worth?
Not much.
Thank you.
Undock.
Let's go around and see if we can find any more parts.
Now that we can fish.
There's gonna be some parts.
Wait a second.
Is this a crab?
That's not a crab.
I'm gonna place my hand on the stone.
It does not respond to my touch.
I see no reason why spooky, scary and cute would be mutually exclusive.
Most people... Wait, what's that over there?
Most people would think so.
Are one or the other?
Can we go in here?
No.
I wanna know what that is.
If anybody has played this, can I get a hint?
I don't know how to stink and find these parts.
Is this a crab?
Please don't be a crab.
Please be real.
Oh, this is a man.
Dang it.
I prefer the crab.
Go inside.
I can't.
I don't have ice.
The ice thing.
To break it.
What the hell is that?
Aberrated ice fish.
Okay, I don't have that.
Hi.
I can't go inside.
Wait.
That just looks like some scrap, but I'll check it anyway.
Just scrap.
It was back near the pontoon.
Like where we were before?
How did the ice become a perfect ledge like that?
Probably aliens?
Can I go inside here?
I didn't realize I'm a jorker.
You're a jorker.
Thank you.
Hot dog.
What's this?
Engar and Boo are ghosts and are cute, so let me know.
Whoa.
Hinged.
What about the unhinged?
What about an unhinged fish?
Would that not be more spooky than a hinged fish?
I'd say.
A pontoon lady.
I think maybe I should turn my light on just in case.
Oh, just kidding.
I don't want my sanity to go so down.
Or maybe I do.
A pontoon lady.
That's a really big one.
Wait, I haven't seen a pirate ship.
Lady?
Where is she?
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Hinged fish.
Maybe this one is friendly.
I probably don't think so.
Where is she?
Is the ice this big?
What's that sound?
I didn't like that.
What the heck are you?
Oh my god!
It's Gundam Man.
She's dredging on my side.
Dredge to meet ya.
I'm dredging any social interaction.
Oh, it's day.
Uh oh, I'm a little crazy.
Get fish.
Go to photographer inside island.
Narwhal breaks ice wall.
Thank you!
Ok, I'm getting fish.
Thank you, thank you.
So, I do remember where the photographer is.
Why is the music like this?
Let's get some more fish then.
I don't know what she wants so we'll just grab a couple.
Oh, this is abyssal.
I don't need you.
Aha!
I'm dredging to this game.
What does that mean?
You think anybody is watching me on the great open sea?
Any sea lovers?
What is that?
Sorry.
What was that?
I don't think that was a good thing.
Did you see that thing underneath the water at me?
It's a shark.
Where did he come from?
H-O-H.
No, S-O-S.
Let's go see what she wants first.
That was sick.
Mother nature is so beautiful.
Okay, let's go in here.
We'll talk to the photographer lady.
She wanted some... Oh my god, leave me alone.
She wanted some fish?
I got your fish.
Hi lady.
Oh, and I guess I couldn't do it before because I...
I didn't have...
The ice rod.
And... So close to being perfect.
Hold on, let's go get another ice fish.
Ice minky.
Lady.
Perfect.
Hello.
That's perfect.
Now cut your engines.
We need to wait in complete silence.
I think I hear something under the ice.
It's really dark.
Was that thing going to be chasing me?
What on earth was that thing?
I'm not sticking around to find out.
Okay.
Me neither.
Bye.
Is that thing going to be chasing me?
I do want to sell my fish though.
Yeah, I don't know... That was a narwhal?
What are they feeding the narwhal in this place?
Give me the... Give me the aberrated one, please.
The next one is definitely a freak.
Ew, it's thawed.
It's so nasty.
I don't like the sound of the ice crackling.
It kind of makes me nervous.
Sorry.
I think we're okay, but let's just park our boat.
Park.
Freak recognizes freak.
It can't match my freak?
I don't know.
Do I look like that?
Alright, let's sell all of our fish.
Yeah, he's stale.
Oh, rotting!
Oh no!
Get rid of him.
And then...
We sleep.
Good night.
And we awake.
And we go out.
Let's see.
Let's put on our haste just in case we get chased by a narwhal.
I want the ice breaker real bad.
Because then we can plow through all of these, I imagine.
Okay, we're going in.
Oh, she really did leave.
Wait, what's that over there?
It's like a whole village.
And I'm guessing the yellow spots are where we get the pieces.
Yes.
What's that?
What was that?
Why did it make that sound?
What was the heartbeat sound for?
I'm scared.
Is
that the narwhal?
I
don't like this.
I don't like this area.
I can dock here.
Wait, there's a frozen man.
This is a frozen guy.
Is this John Carpenter's The Thing?
I'm scared.
Why is this like a horror game all of a sudden?
Which entry do you want to read?
I guess we'll go in order.
Okay.
So that was May 30th, 1847.
Okay, two days later, June 1st.
Okay.
Vivi-Gor, thank you so much for the gift.
You still haven't changed your profile, have you?
Is that a picture of it?
And then June 5th, 1847.
Did they only last less than a week?
There was no mistaking this as a trick of the wind, nor a jest by the crew.
It did not pause for response or acknowledgement, but whispered a cryptic prophecy.
At first, I could not make sense of it.
Three listeners shall hear the heart.
When?
And that I should indulge these listeners.
It spoke of boundless wealth from the stars, and of eye-opening unto the world.
The rest of my sleep was feverish, as my mind was plagued with the sound of the voice.
It spun in my head, echoing even louder.
In the morning, the boat swang, and the navigator came to me separately, claiming to have heard a sound like a heartbeat as the men were digging yesterday.
They indicated a desire to explore the eastern and western reaches of the ice field.
I shall indulge them.
Pronounced Bowson.
What's the ice shard?
Light pierces through the ice, intensifying and concentrating into a glow in the center.
A dark form takes shape against the light.
A place in here to the ice?
A distorted voice echoes from within.
Don't disturb the ice.
What happened here?
It whispered, promised, stones from the stars.
It knew three would hear the heart beneath the ice.
The voice grows louder.
It commanded three listeners, three sacrifices for three eyes.
Nerd.
Four eyes.
I obeyed, but a fourth now sees forever futile.
The shadow is silent for a time.
Slumbering, still, should leave.
It sees you before it whispers.
A pursuit added.
Wait, we can just break the ice?
Who are you?
Captain, the expedition.
Chart the ice field.
Appeared suddenly, through the ice.
Do I?
Wait, hold on.
What do you mean?
What do you mean a pursuit appeared?
Explore the area.
Find whatever the voice the ice was talking about.
A voice speaks from within the ice in the central camp.
A voice spoke from within.
It mentions listeners, eyes, and valuable stones.
It specifically mentioned three.
Or was it four?
I think our character is stupid.
Also, I noticed we have a message in a bottle.
Oh, these are the journals.
I was like, did I miss a message in a bottle?
We gotta go get these samples too.
Let's break the ice, for the bit.
Do not.
Oh, I need a thing.
Risk breaking his senses through the ice, through the shadows.
No hope.
Okay, well I can't help you anyway right now.
I'm scared of leaving here.
I don't have any fish to placate the narwhal.
Maybe I will.
Is he coming for me?
Okay, I think this is just atmosphere.
I think.
Is this just atmosphere?
I can't move, I'm too scared.
I don't want the narwhal to chase me.
It's so ominous.
It really is.
Okay.
Maybe we're fine.
Anyway, let's get some fishies for the narwhal.
Ooh, a prime.
Surely, it will love ice fish.
And we can get...
This species is in no...
No threat of being extinct.
Oh, just kidding.
I depleted the spot.
Oh, okay.
This is fine.
I don't like it.
I don't...
Is that what you humans hear all the time?
Your own heartbeat like that?
Creepy.
I don't like it.
I'm trying to find a place to put the food at.
Kind of what we had it on before.
I don't see any places though.
Just in case this guy comes after me.
It's usually my stomach.
I don't like this at all.
It's so creepy.
Oh, I see one.
Looks like someone built a feeding station.
He will be satiated by offering a fish.
I have many ice fish.
I hope you like.
It doesn't feel, but hopefully it's okay.
What's happening?
Oh my god!
Wait, is he going to go eat it?
We are placating the narwhal.
Oh my god!
Wait, he's kind of cute.
Wow, that was fast.
Okay, cool.
Let's go look around for some other things without worry now.
Can we keep them?
Oh, there was one literally right there.
Okay.
We are looking for other pieces...
to build.
Can I break that down?
We are looking for other pieces to build the ice breaker.
Maybe he will just have one fish on hand at all times.
Oh, didn't you get a map?
You are so right!
What are these sounds?
I do like to throw a few crab pots in this zone for a steady supply of narwhal placation.
Oh my gosh!
Starman, you are so smart!
That's really smart.
I don't have any on me though.
Okay, we can buy some though.
Brian!
Thank you so much for the five gift.
Thank you!
Okay, we got...
We gotta go...
Can I even get to these areas?
Okay, let's go to sleep.
I don't wanna travel through the ice in the dark.
Let's throw some stuff around.
Maybe I...
Actually, I'm gonna use some of these mixed baits as well so that I can just...
My stuff is all over the place.
This is bad.
This is not great.
Throw you in there for now.
I wanna get some extra fish though with the bait.
We sleep!
Undock?
Go here?
How do I use this actually?
I don't remember.
I don't remember how to use the mixed bait.
Oh!
No, it's through here.
I remember.
No.
Oh bait!
There we go.
Big boy.
Okay, surely he'll like that.
World is disappointing right now.
Brian, are you okay?
Are you going through it, man?
Going through it?
What the heck is this?
Lizard!
How
does she smell?
I have a keen sense.
Don't you worry.
Okay.
Map.
We need to go this way.
So let's...is it this way?
I believe.
No, that's the pontoon.
I'm silly.
We need to go this way.
Phil, thank you so much for the five gifted teku.
East and west.
Okay, so in like...
I see!
I see it.
Let's placate.
Wait, but how am I supposed to get in there?
See, this is the issue that I have.
I can't.
Unless I don't need to go there yet.
Maybe...
Let's fish a little.
Gonna grab some more stuff to placate the narwhal god.
Did you wish my friend Mike a happy birthday?
Us British wisps love to tune into your streams before bed with our tea and biscuits at the ready.
Cheerios!
Yeah, I'm not like a...I think, you know...
Saying their first and last name just sounds so formal, no?
I think just a simple...Mike.
Mikey.
Mikey my man.
You know!
Gene, welcome to my friendship.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mike.
Happy birthday.
Mikey.
Okay, hold on.
Now let's see.
How do we get around?
I guess we could go this way instead.
Avoid you.
Avoid that thing.
There we go.
Wait, how do I...
How am I supposed to do anything?
I'm so confused.
I can't...
I can't break the ice yet.
Eh?
Run!
Thank you so much for the 10 yen.
Fill it with fish.
But I don't have one that's just a singular fish.
I see.
He's gotta break it.
No more fish will fit on the...
I see.
Wow, I think we should have backed up a little bit.
I should keep it satisfied at least for a little while.
How is he supposed to eat it if he just breaks it like that?
Second piece acquired.
And I know where the other one was.
I think that he needs to break.
Wait, there's another guy in here.
Why is he so skinny legend?
Also, does this look like a claw?
Or...
I think this doesn't look very good.
Hello funny ghost maid with a comically tall fishing hat.
I'm at work, but I found out today that my cat doesn't need to have her tail amputated.
That's good news.
No, it's fine.
Gosh.
Born too late to explore the world.
Born too early to explore space.
Katy Perry.
Ice shard.
Oh, it's a guy again.
An unnatural spire of ice stands above scraps of snowed over equipment.
A dark shape twists within.
I'm listening to the ice.
An anguished voice cries from deep within the ice.
Hey, the other guy seemed less sussy.
Please break the ice.
The other guy told us not to break the ice.
What's your dealio?
Who are you?
I was... I am the...
How do you say it's pronounced?
It's the Avatar.
Aang, I'll get you out of there.
Bolson.
The expedition.
The terror.
Please, break the ice.
What happened?
The figure contorts through painful shapes.
How's he moving in there?
We saw lights dancing in ice.
Dug deep.
Didn't know.
I heard it.
The heart beating under ice.
The cracking.
Waking.
The noises in the east.
I went.
The captain brought him here to find it.
The hand in the night.
Shadow of claws.
Big icy claws.
The darkness shrinks.
I turned away.
Just a moment.
The pain.
The claws.
My back.
So cold.
So dark.
Under ice.
Please, break the ice.
Bye.
Frozen equipment.
What you got here?
You rummage through the small pile of equipment.
In the snow.
Most items are stuck fast in the ice, but inside a small backpack you find an old journal.
More?
Oh, okay.
June 2nd.
Captain ordered us to make camp on the ice in the center of the lagoon.
After we saw those lights in the ice, everyone got treasure on their minds.
I've seen the light.
There's like a big golden light in the sky.
The claw.
Treasure hunting isn't exactly what the expedition was commissioned for, but given the captain gets the lion's share of whatever we find...
It doesn't surprise me that he is willing to bend the rules a bit.
We start digging after the camp's done.
The sun?
No!
It wasn't the sun!
June 4th.
Spent the day digging down in the ice.
Shovels and ice picks.
Can't remember the last time I was this tired.
We were only allowed two short breaks all day.
Down in the pit, as I rested with my back against the ice, I started hearing something.
It was different to the sounds of the picks.
They were short and sharp.
This was a lull.
This was lull.
A rumble from deeper down.
What's my favorite fish?
My favorite sea creature might be a horseshoe crab.
But that's not a fish.
It's fish adjacent.
Does it count?
I love horseshoe crabs.
They're so cute.
I like... honorary fish?
I don't know about that.
They're not even crabs.
What's my favorite sushi?
Egg.
Eggy.
Manta rays.
I do like manta rays.
Yeah.
Maybe that's my favorite.
Coelacanth?
Oh yeah, those guys are cool.
Let's get back to the journal.
On my first break it was occasional.
Only a few each minute.
But on my second break it had quickened like a heartbeat.
Next day, June 5th.
I can't keep yawning.
Oh gosh, I have late stuff to do tonight.
The captain overheard me telling some others about the sound I heard in the pit.
Before I knew it, I was in front of his desk.
Sure, I was about to have my pay docked.
Hagfish?
What is that?
To my great surprise, he seemed to know something of it already.
He was keen on hearing it described over and over.
He wants me to help locate the source of it.
When he pressed me on it further, I said that it did seem to be coming from the east.
Tomorrow we are setting off to see if we can find it.
Perhaps I shall get a bonus after this is done.
All they think about is money, money, money.
Where does that head to?
It heads out?
Push a mark?
Let's go back where we came.
I can't wait to get the ice breaker.
I don't like staying in this area at night, so...
What we are going to do is...
I like this lizard fish, but we don't need to sell him, I suppose.
We are going to catch some more fish...
before placating our friend.
Some more ice fish.
All this ice breaking reminds me of the kids' board game, Don't Break the Ice with the Plastic Hammers.
I don't think I played that one.
Blob fish!
Did you guys see that angler fish?
I think it was an angler that swam to the top of the water...
and people were like, why are you here?
That's a little concerning.
You shouldn't be up this far.
Yeah, he was a teeny tiny little guy.
He wasn't dead, he was...
But he was dying.
Yeah, he was nearly dead.
He was nearly dead.
Oh, no, that's not what I meant to do.
There we go.
Rest.
Yeah, but people were just like, oh my gosh, it's so beautiful.
He's seeing the sun for the first time.
And I'm like, I think...
I think that will make him even more blind.
Do you like Depth Charge and Rampage from Beasties?
Or Manta Ray and some kind of crab?
I don't remember them, I'll be honest.
Okay, let's go placate our guy.
Thread the needle, thread the needle.
Why is the music so like this?
Uh-oh, I rotted something.
We'll just get rid of it.
I don't know if the amount makes him stay placated for longer or not.
Wait, I kind of want a picture of him.
Look at him chomp.
Nice.
See ya, see ya, see ya.
Okay, go back to haste.
Actually, what if I do this?
No victims!
Reap the corpse of any fish in your sights.
Oh, I don't have any.
Just kidding.
So there was...
One overheat... There, right there.
That we need to get to.
Let's get some more fish.
That's not fish.
Oh, this looks like a big guy.
A goblin shark!
That's so ugly.
Nasty creature.
I see something over here too.
Please don't bully.
Sorry.
I'm not trying to.
He's just got a bit of an overbite.
Let's see.
I don't think this is enough, but we can see all the more we need.
Like how could I... Oh, maybe...
No, see, I don't think that'll work.
Because I don't have any.
If I put down...
Wait.
Ah, okay.
Oh, if only... Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, no.
So close.
If I could get a char and then another ice fish would be good.
Let's try that.
You know where the ice fish are?
Right here?
Okay.
And let's get out our trusty handy dandy.
Easy.
As a young wisp, I yearned for the sea.
But something always got in the way.
But the call of the sea was too strong.
So one day I started dredging.
Is this what he says in the Minecraft movie?
Is this the start of the Minecraft movie or whatever?
Alright.
Oopsie.
Oh gosh, it's gonna be kind of dark by the time he does this.
We might be okay.
I should keep it satisfied at least for a little while.
Dredge goes binten.
I don't think that works.
I don't think that works as well as you think it does.
Let's grab this first.
How many more do I need?
Oh wait, that should be it.
That should be it baby.
Nice.
I'm scared of what's gonna be here at night.
I'm freaked out by this area.
Another makeshift camp constructed in the shadows of a frozen clawed hand.
Someone was seeking these out.
There are very few pieces that still remain.
The lover maid camp here was poorly prepared.
Inside a small bag you find a leather bound journal.
Okay, we're from June 4th where we left off.
Chintzeler, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
The men spent the whole day digging.
They passed up chunks of ice, some as brilliant as crystal.
Others of a deepest bloom were beautiful than sapphires.
But none held the glow we had seen in the night.
However, I did note a disturbance in the ice to the west.
It began as a periodic distant rumble.
As the men dug deeper, the pulsing quickened, strengthening until I could see the ice shifting on the surface.
I was leaving all these giant claws around.
I shall have to inform the captain.
It may as well be that narwhal creature we saw earlier.
Though this did seem much larger.
As I write this, I can already feel my eyes closing.
We will have to wait until the morning.
Okay, June 7th.
This morning the captain appeared out of the fog, rowing alone.
Apparently the boat...
Boatson...
Yes.
Remains at a camp in the east, waiting for nightfall.
That was an excerpt...
The opening of a movie the hag made in the depths.
Shut up!
They were unsuccessful in their search.
But it does make sense that the lights would be more visible at night.
Tomorrow we're to journey together to the west, towards the shifting ice that I reported.
Okay, tomorrow, June 8th.
We are alone on a small island of ice.
After hours of rowing through narrow channels, it rose through the fog.
Our gargantuan, monstrous claw, reaching from the deep.
Whatever creature it once belonged to must be long dead, as the claw is frozen solid.
I wanted to turn back immediately, but the captain insisted we investigate.
He is on edge, his head turning this way and that, listening for the slightest sound.
He is convinced something will happen after dark.
Wait, it's dark for me.
I'm scared!
As the last light from the cold sun fades, I have the sense that it will be a long night.
Can I sleep here?
Oh, I can.
Nice.
Let's undock.
Oh wait, sorry, I forgot to talk to this guy.
Hello!
The voice calls out.
Trapped forever, this prison.
Get me out!
Onix, thank you so much for your bond.
Break it, somehow, free me.
Who are you?
The navigator.
Find safe passage.
Chart the ice it came from.
Beyond.
Break it, somehow, free me.
What happened?
The digging, the cracked ice, like a web, awoke the ice heart.
I told him, whispers in the west, took the bosun, east, returned alone.
The dark figure shudders, sending vibrations through the ice.
The next day, rode here, the captain saw the claws.
Grip my soul, he insisted, made camp, shadow of the beast.
Waiting for the stars, in the night, I saw his shape.
Suddenly, swallowed by the cold, in the dark, he left me.
Why does this sound like...
Why does this sound like a one night stand?
I'm sorry.
Our poor little navigator caught feelings and he left him.
Break it, somehow, free me.
Ok, later.
Bye bye.
We can go back and we can now equip this.
My fish are stale.
It sucks that you can't really make money here, because I feel like I'm giving it all to the damn narwhal.
Okie dokie.
Which I will do right now.
I will give him my fish.
I don't know how often he appears and I don't really want to find out.
Let's take that.
Bye bye.
Alright, let's go attach this.
And then we can break some of these things.
I'm overfeeding him.
I'm gonna make him fat so he can't move.
I'm gonna make him fat so he can't chase after me.
Keep eating, narwhal.
Keep eating.
Chunky boy.
I mean, he might be delicious.
Who knows?
Has anyone thought to eat the narwhal?
Ok, Icy worksite.
That's everything.
Let me just warm my hands up a little then I'll get started.
Installing icebreaker.
It took the whole day.
Alright, I think that should do it.
The front of your ship can now break through chunks of ice.
Go ahead and test it out.
I'll be watching from here.
Does it take up anything in our...
Oh, it doesn't.
That's so nice.
I forgot to mention.
Just let me know if you want to temporarily remove the icebreaker.
And swap it out.
I've been looking through the schematics we found before and there are plans for another device.
For an ice shaper.
That's different to your icebreaker.
It's for cutting chunks of ice.
If you find the missing device, you'll be able to harvest ice blocks for refrigeration.
The blocks of ice can be packed into your cargo to slow fish spoilage.
Ok, that's what it looks like.
Interesting.
Oh wait, I have no fish.
Cool, let's sleep.
And then we shall go and break some ice.
Let's go break the ice, everybody.
Like this?
Do I just ram into it?
Why did that happen?
Am I taking damage?
No.
Neat.
This is awesome.
He's probably hungry after a long night.
And even if he's not, I'm gonna force him to eat?
I'm gonna poison him.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
That's horrible.
Vessels feed on distended fluid-filled body.
A shadow stirs inside.
Do you think there's a man in there too?
Wait.
Yay!
Another one?
Wow!
Wait, I kinda wanna go sell these.
Dang, this bait works too well.
For Gante, actually.
Let's go sell these.
He doesn't deserve my good fish.
I'm just plowing through.
Who needs an icebreaker when you can just ram into it?
539!
Let's go.
And you know what?
I will grab some more bait from the storage though.
I don't see why not.
Look,
even this...
No ice is too large!
I'm gonna... See?
See?
That's not the sun right there.
That's what I was talking about before.
And...
Toothfish.
We'll grab it.
Oh my gosh.
I'm back.
It's night.
Almost.
Maybe we'll sleep.
And then satiate it.
It's not the sun.
Did I ever see the Titanic?
Yeah, what about it?
What about the Titanic?
Lizard.
The movie Titanic?
Yeah.
Oh it's just the ice fish.
Astral ice fish!
Wait, it's so cool!
Constellations of light dances through its body, stitching fin to flesh and spine to bone.
I like it.
How do I know when the narwhal is coming after me?
Oh my gosh.
You know what?
Let's just feed him.
I don't want him on my tail at all.
Oh, I'm stupid.
These are very... These are top delicious fish that any... that money could buy.
I don't think I can... I don't think I can... Yeah.
It's one or the other.
This guy, he looks a little bit... He's got a little bit more bone on him.
Or meat on him maybe.
Maybe not actually.
OK.
So while he's eating that...
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
We're gonna go break the ice!
Again!
Ice axe!
We got it!
Wait, do I need one each time?
You think?
Let's go break the ice.
Ask them about their day.
Ask them if they've seen any good fish lately.
OK, captain.
Anyway...
Cleaving away fragments that fall and shatter.
A frozen heart?
You take the stone and leave.
I mean the...
Thank you.
I don't leave, instead I sleep.
That's not what I expected.
Me neither, actually.
I don't know what I expected, but...
That was...
Interesting.
Hold on, let me actually put this in the storage.
I've been to do that before.
I don't...
Put you in there.
How are my fish doing?
Oh, he's a little stale.
Wait.
Do you hear it?
Creepy.
OK, undock.
Let's go find some more.
In fact, we should know where the second one is.
Over this way.
And I'm gonna feed our guy again.
Get fat!
Eat up!
Yummy, yummy.
You'll never catch me.
Wait, there was this one, right?
Yeah, pretty sure.
And then to the left.
That was kind of fun.
Oops.
Alright, let's go get our next guy.
Hello you, Mr. Navigator.
Our heartbroken little fella.
Break the ice.
You strike hard against the center of the shard where the shadowy shape appears darkest.
A deep crack chases upwards, cleaving away fragments that fall and shatter.
That's a narwhal.
That's a giant narwhal.
I see its horn.
Wait a second.
Take the stone and leave.
Wait, there is no storage here.
What is over here anyway?
I guess we can now like kind of form paths and stuff outside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you a crab or a boat?
Oh, I just, I just, I just...
It looks like I just like pooped on top of it.
No, my face!
You guys didn't see that, okay?
Didn't see a thing.
Yeah, of course you didn't.
Of course you didn't.
I was so scared, I just...
I threw my bait.
Hey, stop!
Don't send that, ducky.
That's gross.
Maybe you can reap your... I don't think I can get it though, because it's right next to the crab.
Alright, my storage.
Throw you in there as well.
Okay, I don't think I want to sleep.
I think I want to go get the next one.
I don't know where exactly it is.
Is it down this way?
I feel like...
Let's go see.
Because the other one was close to the guy.
This one, maybe not so much.
Maybe it's behind him.
Over here?
Where does this lead out to?
Oh no, this just leads outside.
That big chunk of ice that I couldn't go before.
That was a lot of places.
That looks like a giant claw.
It actually is.
You would be correct, my friend.
I'm going to sleep only so that we can... Actually, maybe it would have been...
I'm committed.
I was going to say it would have been easier to see it in the dark maybe.
Oh, wake up, wake up.
Maybe through here?
Ah, I see it, I see it.
Now what are you?
Is this an ice fish?
Oh, it's a tooth fish.
Now there was one area that we haven't been to yet.
So I guess once we get all these guys out, we'll head to that area.
What is this?
Not a crab.
It is a translucent spire of ice.
Stretches down into the darkness.
A pulsing glow rises from the deep, illuminating four round sockets.
What?
So we do need four.
But they said there was only three, but we need a fourth.
Interesting.
The last one must be in that area that we have not been to yet.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let's get our friend here.
How's the ice fishing going, man?
Pretty good, I'd say.
We're just freeing some little zombies from their icy prisons.
You strike hard and it shatters.
And then he closes his eyes.
Good night.
Good night, Mr. Narwhal.
Take the stone and leave.
Yes, we do.
Actually, let's go get the others, maybe.
Maybe we should have them all set up in there.
The ice area is very strange.
So far I'm not sure how to...
Oh, oh, wait a second.
Is that who I think that was?
Was that sound?
The narwhal?
He won't get me if I'm docked, right?
Sorry!
Oh no!
I didn't make him fat enough.
Do I have any food?
I have a tooth fish!
Shoot, what do I do?
Can I evade him?
The music doesn't help here at all.
The music actually does not help here at all.
Hold on, there has to be another one.
Another place to placate him.
No?
Here, let's get another fish.
Perfect.
Big boy.
Big boy for our big appetite narwhal.
My friend can't fish for himself.
Oh, I think that's him.
Awesome and heartwarming music.
If I sleep...
Maybe he'll leave me alone.
Go eat, go get your own food!
You lazy bones!
OK, I don't see him.
Let's go give him his fish.
Before he comes back.
Come here!
Take this.
And this.
And that's all you get.
The other is stale.
We are going to deliver these real quick.
Before I forget.
And here.
I like breaking the ice.
It's kind of...
It kind of feels good.
I like the crack sound that it makes.
OK.
I feel like we might not be doing a good thing, but...
Oh well.
But he's actually closing his eyes, so maybe it actually is for...
The better.
Oh wait, where am I?
This?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK,
we're heading this way.
We're not going this way yet.
No!
It pushed me!
Oh whoops, wrong button.
There's our fourth guy!
This must be...
Nevermind, I thought this was going to be the other ice thing the lady talked about.
Hello!
He's not even looking at us.
He doesn't care.
Nevermind, he is looking at us.
He's definitely looking at us.
Hello Mr. Ice Shard.
He's staring me down.
Oh yeah, he's definitely alive.
The voice abates.
He wants us so bad.
Oh yeah, he does.
What is that thing in the ice?
The shape in the ice shrinks into itself.
What will Mitt do after dredge?
I don't know.
I feel like we maybe still have one more dredge stream.
One or two.
I think maybe one after this.
Because I probably finished the ice today.
I know not.
The eyes open, watching.
Shadow of shadow through the ice, yet more closed still.
It cannot arise.
Break the ice.
Call the heart.
Find the axe.
Undo this.
The betrayer.
So who are you?
First officer.
Safety of the crew.
Failed them.
Should have.
Cursed place.
What do you mean you should have?
Find the axe.
Undo this.
The betrayer.
What happened?
The men saw the lights.
Southern cliffs at night.
Captain and I were looking too.
We rode alone.
He was restless.
Sleepless.
We passed walls of ice.
Finally arrived.
The great horn into view.
That's what I... The big yellow I've been seeing is the horn.
Still need to finish the main story too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think maybe...
We have, yeah.
We still have.
So maybe...
I have the iron rig and then I have the main story, so...
Start a new save and replay it.
Twitch forever.
The words drifted.
Some carried away in the wind.
Pulled ashore.
Quickly.
The size of it.
The light.
Somehow.
He knew.
Eyes were wild.
He was.
Whispering.
Answering.
He said.
I chose him.
Alone.
Avert my eyes.
Could not help.
Look upon.
We fought.
Cold hands.
An iron grip.
Breathless.
Find the axe.
OK.
I have that.
There you go.
You strike hard against the center.
And good night.
Do I get some?
Structure peels open.
Split to its core.
Glistening stone.
And that's our thing.
Very good.
And what's that?
This piece of art.
Wait, what the heck is this?
Orris Anchor.
A fragment of a golden splintered horn.
Discordant buzzing fills the surrounding air.
It yearns for the deep.
Cast?
Wait.
I can cast it overboard.
Wait, is that what I should do?
If it's yearning for the deep, I just... I should send it back there, no?
Just as the child yearns for the mines.
Our little horn yearns for the deep.
Rolling in the deep.
I'm going to sleep.
I really don't want to go crazy in this area.
And by crazy I mean low sanity.
Because this area scares me.
And rest.
Our big fish is probably going to turn into some...
To rot though, I just realized.
That's OK.
There it is.
Little rat.
We got to go feed our narwhal friend.
Low stock.
That should be good enough for now.
Gas, gas, gas.
Let's give him some food.
Leave us alone.
Don't come any closer please.
Oh my gosh.
This would be the perfect...
That would have been so close to perfect.
Or it was so close to perfect.
It would have been perfect.
OK.
Oh, screw you.
Oh, it's just an ice fish.
I like the astral one though.
It's really cool.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Stop please.
Please.
Wait, what are you?
Wait.
Didn't I... I didn't... I left my whole repair kit.
Because I'm stupid.
I was like, I have the ice breaker.
I will need it.
It's been a while since we've had a good bump.
It's because I'm too good at the game.
Finish the main quest in the Pale Reach.
Oh, the glowing light intensifies, feeding into the four stones.
A web of light grows between them, connecting, rejoining, uniting...
What?
That's some fancy stuff.
Wait, then what do I do with this thing?
Cast this overboard to create a reusable two-way portal to Blackstone Island.
Oh, I should have read it.
I should have read the description.
Is that it?
That's everything that's here?
That's it?
Wait, what about the thing the lady was talking about?
We never found that.
Like the ice maker.
Greetings for nerds, we're fishermen.
So true.
The mini ice machine.
Peculiar.
Curious.
So we completed the Pale Reach.
Oh wait, find the ice shaper.
Bring it, wait.
Oh yeah, that's right.
They wanted an aberrated...
Lily Starves.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
You want a hint?
No, it's okay.
I think for right now, honestly, I don't even feel like I need it so much.
Hold on, I'm just gonna re-read all of these.
Very good, very nice.
Go through my encyclopedia.
Oh, there's even more things here that we haven't caught.
Wow, what the heck is this?
Wait, aberration of... I haven't even seen... Oh, this is from a pot.
This is the open ocean.
That just looks like a sunfish.
Pot.
So many fish in this game.
There's so many fish.
Laypine.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Well, cool.
I guess what I'll do is then... I'm gonna undock.
What I'm gonna do is cast aside the little thing here.
So, cast overboard.
And I placed a portal.
Wow.
Our fish are still fresh, so let's go sell them.
I don't wanna travel just yet.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, this just leads outside.
We can still check it though.
Oh, that looks like some... Oh, wait.
Did I just find it?
And... easy.
Yes.
Well, very cool guys.
Oh, that's scary.
I don't like that.
I thought I saw something... in the water.
Don't leave the portal.
Wait, is it a one time use?
Hmm...
Oh, yes?
Oh, you place it down and pick it up.
Uh-oh.
OK.
You can pick it up.
It's a portal wherever you leave it.
I didn't realize.
OK.
OK, shipyard.
Let's repair my ship first.
Oh, pricey.
I think we can do this.
Coastal oceanic.
Awesome.
We're never gonna need this thing again.
OK, awesome.
Oh, yeah, I don't think I had any.
OK.
Very nice.
It's 5, so let's undock.
It's basically day.
I'm not even a little bit crazy.
Then... Oh, wait.
Place it down.
And keep going.
OP net.
For real though.
Wait, this net is so good.
It was worth the...
There's my portal.
Hello.
Oh, yeah, it does say retrieve.
Cool.
Wait, do I have to go back to retrieve it?
Ah, I see.
Oh, I'm kinda crazy.
Oopsie.
My bad.
Let's get out of here.
Back to our normally scheduled programming.
What the hell was that?
It didn't damage my ship.
Stupid drive-by shark.
Wow.
The portal also takes a heavy toll on your sanity.
I can tell.
Golly.
What's this?
Wait, what are you?
What is this?
Oh, it's a barrel-eye.
This is a useless info and off-topic.
Okay, I'll determine that.
I need to share, otherwise I explode.
Your anagrams are timid man or I am fit-tanned mom.
Okay, you weren't wrong, road bird.
Alrighty, let's see.
Our pursuits at the Iron Ring are...
The researcher!
Yes, that's right.
The researcher was going to see about fixing the defenses of the Iron Ring.
Yes, yes, yes.
Hold on, I want to go through this again because there's some that...
Fit-tanned mom.
Big boy.
Oh, big shark.
I'm still a little crazy, but...
That's fine, maybe.
Where am I headed to?
Let's...we need to go to...
What's it?
Oh, here, yes.
Because we gotta go see the lady.
Our researcher friend.
What the?
What do you mean something slithers?
Ew, no!
Oh, no, no!
Being crazy is hard.
Okay.
She is over there.
We can make it, surely.
Nothing slithering onto our boat.
We're getting less crazy.
Full speed.
I might be coming a little red.
Let's fish some.
Oh, wait.
Actually, let's go sell this first because...
After we...let's go sell all of our stuff.
You got this, Minky.
Thanks!
Maybe.
I'm red.
Now I'm blue.
Green.
I'm always green.
You can't stop me.
You can't stop me from being green.
My bad.
405...
That thing is ugly.
Eyes turned upwards, it lies in ambush.
Looking to the sky for falling food.
Stargazer.
That thing is ugly.
Nice.
He's looking at me?
I'm no food.
You don't wanna know what ectoplasm tastes like.
I gotta move some of my stuff around.
We're running out of space.
I do still have my research parts.
And we're gonna move that on board too.
What was I doing here?
Nothing.
Undock.
I sold my stuff.
Now we can go.
Ew, don't do that.
Wait, which one's the...
Vanish.
What
are you?
Oh it's hideous.
Mito is a fish.
In which area would she spawn?
Hell.
Hello researcher.
Hello, a gun.
What do you need?
About those defenses on the rig.
I hope they worked.
The workers on the rig want to find a way to sabotage them.
We'll say yes, they worked.
Good, it's always nice to have additional data points.
Anything else?
Yeah, they want to sabotage them.
Found their conscience, have they?
I suppose they're wanting it to look like an accident.
They wouldn't want to face the corporation's wrath.
They were found culpable.
Dia!
Thank you for the raid!
Hello party people.
Hello!
Thank you!
Welcome, welcome.
My name is Mint Phantom.
I always forget to introduce myself during raids.
Yeah.
Bugbug, thank you for the gift.
And I saw that.
Distracting super chat.
Nailed it.
Furby, thank you for the gift.
We love Miss Freaky Phantom.
That's my name, don't wear it out.
Yeah, playing Dredge, I like this game.
This game is a lot of fun.
Ahuel, thank you for the gift.
Ducky, thanks for the gift.
Resting glitch face, thank you so much for the five gift.
I do have a pleasingly elegant idea, actually.
We don't have to sabotage the defenses in a traditional sense.
If you recall, they emit a sort of word.
At the moment, they're broadcasting a warning.
Flee.
We can change that.
I have other recordings of other words.
Instead of a warning, it could broadcast an invitation.
CC, thank you for the five gift.
There's one in particular I've been referring to.
It's by its closest human analog, Rise.
Rise.
I'll prepare some blueprints for the module.
You'll have to assemble it and slot it into the top of the black box.
Uh-oh, I might sneeze.
Some blueprints.
Oh my gosh, I wish.
I'm here from the MGS playthroughs.
Thank you.
Glad you liked them.
I kind of like Metal Gear.
It's like a bit of a thing that I enjoy.
Let's see.
Let's sell this bad boy.
Holy cow!
472 doubloons!
Let's go.
We're back to getting big money back.
We're back to being the richest pirate in the sea.
Yeah, I mildly tolerate it.
It's a bit of a secret.
What else can we buy?
Buy, buy, buy.
Oh, we probably want to undo this one, huh?
Wait.
Sorry.
I'm yawning again.
Uninstall.
Uninstall, uninstall.
And let's do the infused one.
Nice.
What else can we install?
Nothing.
I don't think a single thing.
Wait, so do I have to wait for her to do the blueprints?
Override the defenses.
I should construct an override at the loose panel in the defense tower.
Oh, okay.
I will do that.
Wait, is this the loose tower?
Outpost.
No.
Nah, there's nothing here.
Okay.
One year since my capture.
Yeah.
How are you enjoying the simple life?
Minta with 2000 hours in an MGS game.
It's okay.
Yeah, you know.
You gotta play it cool.
I'm good at playing it cool.
Everybody knows.
Yeah, I'm just playing it cool.
I'm just, you know, I'm such a cool cat.
Lady, are you done?
What do you need?
Oh, it's nothing.
Okay.
Maybe I go back.
Let's go back to the...
This way?
What is... Wait, what's that?
Is this a...
Yeah, it's a crate.
We like to collect these.
We don't care what's in them.
We just like to collect the crate.
Oh, this way.
Yeah, I'm very cool.
What does this thing do?
Ice and shallow.
I think those were the new ones that the old net didn't use.
It goes to ice cold for a reason.
I'm too cool.
I'm too calm.
I'm too collect...
Collect...
Tuna.
Razor mouth tuna.
Oh, it's just a squid.
Squid.
Are you ready, kids?
Aye aye, captain.
I can't hear you.
Who lives in a pineapple under the sea?
Minky.
I'm a very huge fan of your Lieutenant Dan cosplay.
Very cool and very accurate.
Accurate.
What do you mean accurate?
What do you mean by that?
I think I need to lose a limb though to make it more accurate.
I do not like those guys.
What the hell is this thing?
A moonfish.
What's that sound?
Skeletal moonfish.
Why do things sound really bad right now?
Let's dock.
Been trying to keep a record of all the black liquid... the dark liquid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't care.
Ghostly body.
Ghostly.
How's me?
Moonfish.
It's kinda cute.
I'm gonna feed all of the stuff to the generator.
I know you get less money, but it's ok.
Defenses.
The rise.
Rise, my children.
Rise.
What's that?
Wait, this seems really bad.
Wait, all the people are gonna die, no?
Maybe not.
My boat!
Is it ok?
Barely missed.
Oh my god.
See ya!
We've been saved!
With the last scraps of metal still falling from the destroyed drill tower, the executive boards his helicopter.
Rotors already spinning.
Is everyone alright?
All accounted for in the factory.
Yep, foundry's fine.
I guess we'll wait for our airlifts outta here.
There's no way I'm traveling anywhere by boat.
Yeah, I'll sit tight for now.
Fishermen, the main buildings are mostly undamaged, so if you still need stuff made, we can sort you out.
I overrode the rig's defenses and that's...
Is that it?
Is that... everything?
For the iron rig?
Besides collecting samples?
Construct buildings on the rig.
I haven't built a tier 4 factory.
Wait, that was it?
Tier 4.
Okay, let's go do this.
Undock.
Let's go find a crate, which I guess I have right here.
I have listed on the map.
Only thing left is samples.
I think so too.
Neat.
So then maybe next stream we really can just finish the game.
Unless I stream for longer today.
I did start earlier because I was like, maybe I'll stream for a long time.
But I'm actually starting to get hungry.
Hungry, hungry, hungry.
There.
Let me eat more popcorn.
I don't have anymore popcorn.
What's for dinner?
Maybe ravioli.
I don't know yet.
From the chef?
No.
Heck no.
But I'm still kind of craving salmon from yesterday.
Salmon.
Fish fear me, doki fears me, women fear me, but snakes obsess with me.
That's like just my delusions though.
I wish that were real.
Guys, do you think snake would like me?
You can be honest.
Do you think snake would like me?
He liked Emma.
Why is this lady...
She talks, or she like...
She hums like a Minecraft villager.
That'll do it for the factory.
Sorry.
Build all levels of all buildings on the rig.
What do we got here?
Exotic bait.
Oh my gosh, 700 dollars.
Insta crab bait.
That's actually really nice, no?
Wait, we need the mixed bait.
We need a dark splash and we need some rot.
Yeah baby!
I just need a little bit of a dark splash.
And then the aberrated bait, which I still have.
But I think some insta crab would be great.
Would have been so useful.
I know.
What do you need again?
Where are... Oh these are all volcanic.
That was like dunklesores.
What the heck is a dunklesores?
OK.
So...
I guess it's time to go.
19, I fear you're too old for snake's taste.
I
won't entertain this slander.
Even if it's accurate.
Don't like that.
Let's go to sleep here.
So we haven't really explored this area at all.
Mito aren't you forever 19?
Yes!
I am forever.
But Eva, Eva that's a naked snake.
Holy cannoli.
Alright.
I can't see anything.
I was like, oh I'll see better in the morning.
Can't see.
Can't see anything.
So apparently here there's like little fishies that attach to you.
Or they call for their mom.
Or something.
Think snake would kill billions for Minky.
I don't think so.
I don't think he'd like me.
I'm gonna sell my fish.
Wow!
We caught a sailfish.
That's crazy.
Throw these.
Oh no!
Gonna have to start really doing some Tetris here.
He didn't specify.
Any of them.
Ok.
So here...
Let's go through our things again.
Search for relics.
Find the watch and devil's spine.
So that's where we are at now.
And light the statues with the fathomless flames.
Ok.
And catch rare fish.
Oh we got to catch a coelacanth.
Solidus would love you maybe.
I like Solidus.
I think the only one I wouldn't go with is Liquid.
So I gotta eat some goldfish.
Coelacanth is here.
Goliath tiger is in the swamp.
Oh!
Thank you.
I think your only hope is Venom?
Don't say that.
Don't say that!
Guys, I'm out of goldfish.
No!
Mogu mogu.
Do they have goldfish crackers in Japan?
You don't like Venom?
No, he's so boring!
I
need my man to be a little bit more unhinged.
And talkative.
What do I just do there and talk the whole time?
Yeah, let's not get into spoiler territory though.
We'll call it here so we avoid spoilers.
I think I'm gonna... I don't think we'll get any more.
I don't want to sell this just in case we get more slots, you know, but...
Which MGS gal is your favorite then?
That's hard!
Maybe Meiling.
19 inches of Venom.
What are you talking about?
Alright.
So we gotta go light up some stuff here.
Which... Let's just go to the X's on the map.
Maybe?
What is this?
Something shiny.
So it's like right here, no?
Oh my god.
I just... I just... I just tapped it.
I didn't mean to.
A stone shrine.
An upright slab bears a carving.
Two heavily plated creatures locked in battle.
A lower slab holds two shallow grooves.
What the hell?
Okay.
Let's go get our insta-crab.
Bait.
Let's get the insta-crab bait.
Return the slab.
I gotta... I gotta repair my ship first.
Well,
wait a second.
I do have a large crab pot.
What if I just leave it here?
But, I wanted to get some slime.
And...
Look.
I wanted to get some slime, so let's get this as well.
Come here slime.
What are you?
What is this?
And pop!
Nice.
Alright.
It might take over that guy.
We'll put it in like the corner.
Okay.
Normal fish.
Normal is subjective maybe.
Can I go over these?
I'm gonna test it.
I can!
I was for sure thinking they would hurt my vessel.
What do I need from this one?
Let's see.
Maybe we can stick this guy some...
Oh.
Is it still chasing after me?
No?
Oh gosh.
Maybe I can banish these things.
Why can't I ever... Oh, banish.
Why can't I ever remember what each thing does?
Maybe... Let's go around.
Oh.
Never mind.
They are everywhere.
Let's see.
Let's try it.
I banished it!
Okay,
I guess that worked.
Very cool.
And I'm a little crazy.
Might not be the best place to be crazy in, but...
A stone shrine.
Two malformed fish writhing under the sun.
That's it?
Can it be any fish?
The what's it called seems pretty big, so...
They are calling their mom!
Just two abnormal fish.
Okay.
First we are going to go get our crab thing.
Six!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Any two aberrations.
Nice.
Okay.
That doesn't seem too bad.
You might have some in your net.
I do have one tiny guy!
I do!
The cell to the generator.
This guy...
He's in storage.
Wait.
There he goes.
Into cargo.
There we go.
Okay, we have one tiny little man.
And then let's go to the factory.
And we'll get our tier 4 crab bait.
Nice.
Attracts the rarest of fish.
Wait a second, we can make this too.
Fancy.
Glad to have been here a year.
Excited for more!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for a whole year.
I don't like the music here.
It annoys my ears.
It's just a little too much.
Oops, my bad.
We go back.
This place spooks me though.
All the places spook me.
One year of making... Thank you!
Alright, before our little guy rots away...
Let's... Oh, he's still fresh actually.
Let's go check our crab pot.
What?
I don't want to go back over there until we have a second freaky guy.
What the hell is that?
Not friend.
Not good.
That's the mom?
Oh, that's the mom!
Come on.
What the hell is that?
She's not coming this way, is she?
Nah, she's chilling over there.
No.
Yes, bait.
It counts as a bait, no?
Yeah, okay.
Wait, but...
Wait, huh?
Wrong bait.
Did I use the wrong one?
How do I know which one I used?
Oh, it's the crab bait.
Aren't those the guys I need?
I got both of them.
Easy peasy.
Where is your mama?
Maybe it's fine.
Okay, it sounds kinda... I think that's her sound.
She seems a little far, so...
Alright, we light her up!
These guys look expensive.
The rock splits with an almighty crack.
It crumbles away, revealing its core.
Okay.
How are you doing?
He's a little stale, but not dead yet.
And some wood.
Do I light you up?
Is that it?
It's crossed off the map, so I guess so.
Very nice.
I'm gonna sell these then.
Maybe get some ice.
It probably did...
It probably did... Yeah, I had ice in it.
Definitely...
Definitely melted.
As ice tends to do.
Well...
Maybe we'll get something.
Maybe we'll get lucky.
Let's just try this.
We might get lucky.
Wow, this thing is freaky!
Giant dragonfish.
I'm gonna sell that.
I think I might just have to get rid of this little guy.
We'll find another one, I'm sure.
If I get one, I won't remove it.
It's my fault.
I shouldn't have removed it from the net.
That was my fault.
Let's just sell him before he... Also, he's oceanic.
Does that even count?
Does it have to be volcanic?
Oceanic?
We're officially full.
Wait, let's use some of our research thingies.
We can... Do I need this?
No.
We can research more crab pots.
Oceanic.
We'll keep him in there for now.
I'm gonna go around.
Let's check out what the other...
guy is.
The other...
All the way over here.
What is this?
Oh.
That's just a whale.
How curious.
Gosh, this area sucks.
I don't like it.
It's so hard to maneuver.
A stone tablet.
Wait, you mean pursuit added.
I'm not doing enough for you?
Visit the trader.
Oh, take the tablet to the trader.
I found an ancient stone tablet with a strange glyph on it.
Looks similar to the ones I saw on the trader's desk in Little Morrow.
Like down here?
Trader.
Actually, this is good.
Because we have a bunch of stuff to sell.
So let's just do that.
Tablet lore is heavy in this game.
What?
Oh no, seriously?
Wait, is he the trader?
What is it?
Oh, he's the collector.
What's in the workshop?
You go inside, taking a moment to let your eyes adjust to the dim light.
You find some horrifying creations.
Wait, what is this?
A symbol of the deep is carved into this small talisman.
It's sure to draw the attention of those attuned to it.
Mine, no.
The bony blades of this grotesque engine are...
Oh, it's an engine!
But mine is better.
Oh man.
Mine is better.
OK.
Trader.
We have a lot of stuff to sell to this guy.
So actually it's good to come back here.
DLC starter gear.
Oh, this guy!
What can I do for you?
Show him the tablet.
The trader takes the stone tablet from you and inspects it closely, turning it over in his hands.
Remarkable.
Yes, I do believe this is a fragment of a larger arrangement.
He reaches up to a high shelf and brings down a similar looking stone, albeit one covered in much more dust.
Some years ago I acquired this other piece.
You found this near those ruins in Devil's Spine, didn't you?
Yeah.
Well, I suspect there will be more out there.
I'll hold on to this for now and study it further while you search for the other fragments.
In the meantime, do you have any trinkets?
I have so many trinkets, sir.
Oh, that's tea.
I have this.
Actually, sell...
OK, I have three trinkets.
I might have overestimated how many trinkets I had for you.
I might have gotten a little overzealous about my trinket amount.
Oh, my bad.
Sell all trinkets.
Bye bye.
And let's go to the flag guy, the painter.
Deliver flag.
No, I like my pirate flag.
Leave.
Cool.
Unlock.
Find more tablets.
So there's only three statues?
Why did it look like there were so many more on the map?
I had one.
Wait, I had one more?
What did I have?
Oh, this.
Yes, the sextant.
Yes, I always forget that it is this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
It looks like a...
A piece of a boat, so I forget.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna sell my fishies while we're here.
Make color boat?
I don't have the cram for it.
I haven't seen that strange red light in a while.
And we're gonna repair.
Alright, so we need to get some...
I think I asked earlier, and I didn't check what you guys said if you said it.
For the map, or for the light that requires the mutated guys...
Can it be anyone from anywhere, or does it have to be volcanic?
For the mutated fishies, for the lamp.
If anybody knows.
I think it's Annie.
That would be great.
Anyone from anywhere?
Let's go back then.
I saw one over here.
Yeah, I see it lit up in the distance.
You!
What is this anyway?
Oh, it's a snake mackerel.
There, one.
One moment please.
Let's go sleep.
Oh, I was gonna say, that's a boat over there.
It's not a boat.
It's the port.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright.
What's this guy got to...
We don't have anything to talk to him about.
Statues.
We don't have anything here.
Stone columns.
Nothing there.
Okay, I've looked at all this stuff already.
Oh, Andrew!
Thank you for the brain.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello people, I'm playing this game called Dredge.
My name is Mifrater.
It's kind of spooky, but also really fun.
I think I can... Wait.
Why is it so red?
Why is it actually so, so red?
Holy cannoli.
We gotta get another freaky fish.
Scary, but fun.
It's pretty cozy, I mean, all things considered.
It is pretty cozy.
What is this?
Oh wait, I can probably blow this up, huh?
Use explosives.
I gotta go get some explosives.
Let's go get some.
She should have some, no?
The lady.
I don't like the mama fish.
Indy, if you had a boat.
Let's get some explosives.
That looks to be like maybe another...
Oh, okay.
We're docking here.
Oh, she sells ice even.
Oh, that's good.
You know what?
Why not?
Let's just buy some ice.
Let's keep our fish a little... It's stale, but we can make it not so stale.
I wish someone would dredge my marriage from the depths.
Am I right, fellas?
Sir, I'm a VTuber.
Sir?
Big ol' crabs.
Hold on, sorry.
I know I keep going back to her, but I'm just gonna get rid of stuff that...
Like this stuff, you know?
Okay.
Just so we can have enough room.
And just in case I hit something, I don't want to lose it on accident.
Sir, this is a Wendy's.
I kind of want a Wendy's.
I have a go-to Wendy's order.
Because Wendy's sells baked potatoes.
I like that a whole lot.
I like their baked potatoes.
I mean, it's just a baked potato, but... I don't know.
Use explosives.
Noice.
Drop the meal.
Baked potato.
That sure was unfortunate.
Let's go put this guy into the fountain.
Or not fountain.
Wait, what's it called?
Wait, where am I?
I think I'm lost.
Hold on.
Where was it?
The lantern.
The light.
Why is it turned so red?
I don't like this.
I think... Was it over there?
Yes.
Spicy nugs.
Uh-oh.
I think mama's coming.
Wait mama, please wait.
Mama.
Where
is she anyway?
I need... I almost hit that rock.
The wind blows.
Please leave me alone.
I'm not in the mood for your...
Wait.
Over there.
Wait, I need this.
No!
I'm volcanic!
Ok, we got to buy a new rod.
We got to buy a new rod.
Ok.
Yeah, I do have a few holes.
Oh, my light went out.
I'm punching the air right now.
No!
Let's buy this.
I have... Wait, I have the rod?
Oopsie.
How much was it?
Anyway, sell that.
Oops.
Will it fit?
Yes, it will.
What?
Anyway, it's morning.
Why can't I find this stinking thing every time?
Get off of me!
You're making me slow.
Why am I so bad at finding this thing?
Wait, what's in there?
Why does it look different every day?
No one likes to be slow.
What's that in there?
Is that another...
Oh, wait.
You know what?
We're just going to go buy a bunch of C4.
And not have to deal with it.
And deal with those stinking fish.
Except I'm going to have to deal with them right here.
Leave me alone, please.
Mama!
Please leave me alone.
Mama, please.
Oh my god.
The
rock splits and almighty... What the heck is this?
To my storage you go.
And you too.
We lit a flame!
I don't like this area.
It's so frustrating.
Blip bloop.
Yeah, we're going to read that...
Soon.
Okay, we can read it now.
They're all gone.
Oh wait, I have to go to my storage.
Okay.
What is that?
This freaky thing is a stone tablet surrounded by tooth and bone.
A glyph of a hook is carved into the center.
Okay.
Wait, I can put it on my...
Oh wait, fishing speed...
I'm sorry, 375%?
But what does it... It just gives speed?
It doesn't catch any types, it's just faster.
Your expression makes me think you pooped yourself.
Why would you send that to me?
What do you think I'm an actual baby?
You think I'm like a real baby with diapers?
Is
it because I'm saying mama?
I'm not talking about a real mom.
I'm talking about this ugly fish lady mom.
Fish mom.
Aren't you?
No!
Does 19 sound like a baby?
19 forever even?
Don't send poop.
I sprung a leak.
Oops.
I'm just casually sinking.
Let's sell all of our fish.
Nice.
Making a big bunch of money.
Anyone under 20 is a child to me.
Hey Christian, I know you might be worried, but not really the place.
Trying to remember the rules.
Thank you.
19 is baby.
Can't drink you baby.
Depends on the country.
Also, I don't drink anyway.
Also, you don't even know what age you need to be as a ghost to drink.
So, you don't even know.
You're so wrong.
Alright, we got two.
We just got to go get... What was this one?
I don't think we even...
Oh, I was going to buy C4.
That's right.
Give me that.
I'm not even buying more ice.
It's a scam.
Where is it?
Over yonder.
Ghost drink booze.
Oh,
there it is.
The hell is that sound?
What do you wish?
What do you require?
Or...
How do I acquire these?
Wait, I feel like I've gotten at least this thing.
The one on the... Wait a second.
Pale skate?
From a pot?
Wait, I've gotten both of these before.
Wait, I've gotten these before.
I just have to get them again.
Ghost shark.
So...
I have to fish the ghost shark though.
So that guy sound... I heard...
She sounded awfully close, so...
Wait, what's this?
Are you a ghost?
Oh my gosh.
Easiest...
A what?
A rapt shark.
I don't like that.
Wait, they are not going to get my trophy.
It's depleted.
I told you guys she sounded close.
Ok, maybe from our crab pot...
Pick up.
Please repair.
That was so close.
Alright.
We are going to sell you.
Or first we are going to repair our... We are going to repair the crab pot.
Because we are going to...
Wait, but we can just fish another ghost shark since it's right next to her.
Or right next to the thing.
I think we can... I think we can sell all of these, honestly.
And make the most out of our money, baby.
Ok.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
You can banish mommy.
Ok.
Mommy.
Oh, I should have...
I'm a silly goose.
I should have put this down first.
It did say that we can get her in the crab pot.
Troll.
Oh no, it's not the pot.
I'm a dummy dum-dum, sorry.
Hold on, I'll show you guys.
See, it says rod or troll.
Ok, so we gotta find the pale skate.
Or was it not?
Wait.
Yes?
Oh, spot a fish of each category.
Oh, neat.
Alright, well we found that guy.
Alright, let's go over there.
Twisted shark.
Don't get it twisted.
Is it you?
Oh, it's you.
Ok.
Let's get another one, just in case.
Well, this wasn't so bad.
I say before eating my words.
Get it twisted.
You mean now you just need the ghost shark again?
Yeah, we can get him right where we got him before.
I'm so over the goop.
It's like so...
What the heck?
You see that?
Wait.
The goop is like so last stream.
We're beyond the goopening.
Uh-oh.
Surely more will respawn.
Let's just put this guy in for now.
Oh gosh, she sounds so close, you guys.
Mama sounds so close.
Wait, hold on.
I use my handy dandy...
Wait, what the heck?
Oh, that's a thing?
It's kind of cool.
Is this the water temple?
Do you still have bait?
Oh, on me?
No.
No, I don't.
It's okay, we can just wait for another...
Sawfish.
We can just wait for him to... for it to respawn.
It will.
Or maybe we caught one in our net.
Is eating volcanic fish raw?
Still sashimi or are they kind of pre-cooked?
That's a good question.
Oh my god.
Hi mama.
Is she coming after me?
Oh, uh-oh.
Hey, get off of me.
Uh-oh, now she's coming after me.
She wasn't before, she sure is now.
Wait, go away you stupid kids.
Mom, control your children.
I need leashes or something.
I gotta say, baby leashes are probably one of the greatest inventions ever.
Get off my line.
That's a child right there.
That's a hot take, really?
I don't think it should be.
I think they're like, so helpful.
But then what?
Does the kid have a dignity?
Is the kid like, oh no, I'm on a leash, I'm like a dog.
No, the kid doesn't care, it's a baby.
This is no.
Wow, 704 dollars.
Let's go.
And I'm gonna buy some more.
C4.
And I'm gonna sleep and we're gonna hope that the guy respawns.
Actually, I'm gonna buy some bait too just in case.
Alright, sleep.
Those kids are the worst.
China!
I cared.
You don't remember.
Don't lie.
This guy is so cool.
Wait, he's so cute.
Oh my god, he's so cute.
I had a leash, apparently, loved it.
And I turned out.
You turned out alright.
You became something.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifts.
Thank you.
Yeah, you turned out.
Oh, I'm too close.
Why can't I just put my arms down?
No!
One ghost shark please.
Ok, I see her.
I'm not gonna, she does not bother me.
I'm not gonna let her, she does not control my life.
This, this, this...
Oh god, she's so close.
Oh my god, she's so close.
The rock splits and we get this.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god.
There's so much in here I wanna grab, but...
Mommy scares me.
Ok!
Now we...
Go back to our guy.
Light the statues, what do you mean 0 out of 3?
Oh, I have to go take the wisps.
I have to go take you guys.
It says the naked Murphy.
What do you mean naked?
Why are we naked?
The leash I got when I was a kid had a buckle.
It was bazazzle?
I've never had a leash, but I also turned out...
But, it's not the leash's fault.
Little wisp, wisp, wisp, wisp, wisp.
What are you?
Oh, just a stinking snake mackerel.
Oh my gosh, when I would go on a boat sometimes...
That was my favorite thing is when it would go like...
On the water.
Ok!
Let's go into my storage, grab you guys.
Throw this in here, throw that in there, throw this in there.
This guy is just chilling.
But, it looks like he's picking them up, like clogging them.
Statues.
The left statue.
A cold flame roars in the statue's hands.
Alright, middle statue.
Right statue.
What's gonna happen?
Preparations are complete.
The fanatic awaits.
Hold on, let me go sell my crab.
I love how as the fishermen we play like for no one team.
We're just like, yeah, I'll do it for some scrap.
Yeah, ok.
Oh my goodness.
Slowest, ok.
Holy cannoli!
We're making such, sorry I always do this, we're making tons of money.
Nice.
Oh my gosh, we're almost at five thousand dollars.
Cash money, baby.
Do it for some scrap.
This area sucks, it's so foggy you can't see anything.
It's so foggy and red, my eyes.
The scientist quest?
Wait, is this gonna end the game?
Does this end the game?
Not yet?
No?
Ok, then we're fine.
What is it?
Wow, ok, hello?
The flames are lit.
I can feel it.
The chill of the deep torches us now.
It is time.
Come.
We follow him up the steps of the temple.
At the top is a black stone altar.
Stacked high above the altar are layers of dark, damp wood.
Been a long, unfun day.
No!
Serenus, I hope it gets better.
He draws the antique pocket watch from his robe.
It sways hypnotically in the breeze.
Is he gonna hypnotize me?
Sexy.
It is almost yours.
May it mark the start of your journey.
And the end.
Still holding the pocket watch, in one hand he clambers atop the pyre and raises his skull.
Not skull, sorry.
His scroll.
Oh no, he just like...
He just rips his head off.
His skull metal.
He begins to chant.
What are you doing?
He ignores you.
I had a feeling that would happen.
The wind picks up.
Swirling sea spray around the altar.
A cold blue flame rises from the sodden wood at his feet.
Stop this?
Says nothing.
The freezing blaze climbs his legs.
His chanting continues, no pain detectable in his voice.
Oh wait, he's on fire?
Oh no!
He lifts his arms skyward.
Seconds later, the inferno engulfs him.
Oops!
It rages for a moment, then abruptly dies away.
A cold mist pools around the floor of the temple, briefly before the wind sweeps it into the sea.
No trace of the fanatic remains.
Oh no!
The pyre is cold and damp.
We're going to expect it and we get our pocket watch!
We take the pocket watch.
It's freezing cold.
It vibrates in your palm.
Clock hands spinning wildly below the cracked face.
So he burned himself?
I guess so.
Freaky little guy.
Is that the last relic?
Yes.
It is the last relic.
Let's see.
I might actually call it here guys and have the last part of...
Because I still want to do the aberrated ice fish.
No, sorry.
The devil's spine fish.
Well, I feel like maybe we can do these.
Oh, I need the different version of the... Hold on.
Maybe I can keep going a little bit more.
Let's see.
Hold on.
I do have some stuff I gotta do tonight, which is why I had a bit of an earlier stream today.
One thing that kind of sucks about having meetings with Japanese companies is you have to have meetings with them on Japanese time.
Let's go see what we need for the other...
What's the word?
The other rod.
The things you do go well.
Thank you!
I'm trying to plan lots of cool stuff.
Do you have 3AM meetings?
Not today.
Actually, I've never had a 3AM meeting luckily, but today's meeting is at 1AM for me, so...
It's a factory, right?
This infused fireproof... Wait a second.
I needed this anyway.
Oh, I sold it.
Anyway, then we'll end it here, because I gotta get some more goop.
I gotta get this.
There's a little more things I wanna do before we end off, so... Next time!
We get the samples for this...
We get the samples for this guy, I cannot think with this stinking music.
And...
It might be a bit of a shorter one, maybe.
I don't know, maybe... Should I just...
After I give the final trinket, is there way more?
Hot dog!
Thank you!
Wait, 30 minutes more?
Wait, people are saying you're really close.
Hold on.
You'll need to do a bit for the second ending.
I guess then we can do the first ending and the second ending...
Next time then?
Maybe?
What do I keep hearing?
I guess it's the game.
It's pretty short after this trinket.
And then if I have the second... I maybe have 30 minutes left?
Really?
What do?
I'm not like, attempting to 100% the game.
I think maybe I'm just feeling a little tired for today.
So I'm kind of like, not as into it as I have been in the past.
Maybe I'm over dredged.
Oh no!
I mean, this is part 5, so...
What should we do?
Should we finish up?
We can do everything next stream.
Okay, we'll just do it next stream.
Maybe I could do like a...
What do I keep hearing?
It must be in the game.
It sounds like a cat.
I'm getting out of here.
I'm a dog.
I guess then...
Starting my mandatory military service tomorrow!
So no more minky stream for the next month.
Master Paladin!
Fooled me.
Good luck!
Friendship ended with dredge.
Blue Prince is my new best friend.
I feel like that.
I do feel like that a little bit.
Okay.
Maybe I could do like another afternoon stream.
And it can be kind of small and then I can do a longer stream that night, next week.
I think that will work.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that could work.
If you want to end the story, deliver the pocket watch.
You can get the rest of the fish and members if you want to.
That's true.
I don't know.
Should we just finish the story then?
I can't tell what I want to do!
I'm sorry.
I'm so indecisive.
Finish it?
Let's finish this.
Finish it for Master Paladin.
You're so right!
You won't be able to see the story.
Deliver the relic.
He approaches, drawing closer with an incessant ticking.
You have the pocket watch.
You take out the watch.
Its once frozen hands are now inexplicably twitching in a rhythmic struggle.
Trying but failing to move forward.
You place it in front of the collector.
Flip a coin.
Heads to finish it.
Heads!
Though it has been some decades since I last laid eyes upon this, the sound of its mechanisms has grown no less unpleasant.
And with that, our collection is complete.
I must admit, I am surprised.
I did not think you had the determination for such a job.
Where's your motivation?
Now, with these five relics in our possession, only one thing remains.
I suspect you know that by now.
Know what?
It will become apparent soon enough.
I don't know anything, mister.
We must take one final voyage.
This time, I will be with you.
I'm ready.
Warning, you are entering the final phase of the game.
Your progress will not be saved from this point onwards.
You wish to continue?
Yes.
Warning, one more time.
Your progress will not be saved from this point onwards.
Okay, so that means if I want to finish anything else, I can.
The relics are coming with us.
We should wait for the fog to thicken.
With luck, the seas will remain unaware of our intentions.
Yeah, you can come back.
Waiting for the right time.
Now, our destination is the open expanse to the west of Great Morrow.
It's marked on the map.
We must not tarry on the open waters.
Not with such a significant cargo.
Make haste!
So no open waters?
Got it.
Wait, where is he?
He's not on my ship.
Here.
Greater Morrow.
Please sir, I'm nothing but a simple fisher ghost.
Okay, uh...
Eco?
What do you mean we shouldn't go on the open waters?
What's the issue?
Oh, my bad.
Is something gonna come get me?
I dare you to try.
I like the way the...
I like the way the cracks in the ocean look.
They're so neat.
Almost there!
This is the place.
This is where she was taken from us, and where we can at last bring her back.
Only here, and only because of what we've achieved.
He opens the book and begins to read aloud.
To release a lost one frozen in time.
He throws the pocket watch overboard.
And tethered by chains in the deep.
He throws the necklace overboard.
Bind them to this world once more.
He throws the ring overboard.
Open the door to the starry heavens.
He slots the key into the lock of the music box.
Is this guy just like trying to bring back his girlfriend or something?
Is all this meant for some guy who's simping for a lady friend?
And lay the weary world to rest.
He throws the music box overboard.
Its key left unturned.
The achievement was find a use for the relics.
Reread the notes chronologically.
No way.
Oh
my god.
Our lady friend comes with a little extra.
Two for one deal baby.
That's it.
Oh, oh no.
Oopsie.
Oops.
The good ending.
Hear me out.
Who wouldn't do this for a Kamiyoshi?
Don't be real.
Oops.
She came back with bigger asset.
The ultimate super chat.
Wow.
Big oopsie.
The music is so awesome.
So epic.
Sorry, I didn't mean to block the credits.
The true ancient one.
Wait a second.
What do you mean by that?
This Kaiju is kind of cute.
It has a cool hat.
God, this music is so good.
Not old, ancient.
Would it be better if I looked like this instead?
Yeah.
Wait, hold on.
Let me fix my chat.
There we go.
Ancient and dimensional.
Nice.
The credits have gone on for so long the soundtrack ended.
I didn't know this was Team17.
Not the Latin singing of fighter jet boss is about to turn face combat style.
You hear like the crackling.
I wonder what happened with the lady at the lighthouse.
So what happens to us?
There is no special after credits scene.
Oh, really?
Wait, I just heard another boat go...
We get a CGF as well.
This whole thing was basically just like a blind date.
So he got his girl back and he's like, by the way, she has a really great friend.
And she's so... she's a great person.
Creature.
Great thing.
She's great.
And it would just mean the world to us if you met her.
Just give her a chance.
She has a great personality.
Find the old mare for the alternative ending.
There are honestly so much that I did not do.
Like I didn't... there was like those frozen guys that asked for fish.
I didn't do those.
Obviously, I didn't finish the iron rig thing, but I don't think that would be a new ending.
The mito that sold the world!
There's so much more also to explore here.
I'm just going to skip the rest.
Just because you said there was no other ending, right?
So...
There are no DLC endings, I think.
Best ending.
This ending changes a little if you do the thing to unlock the other ending.
Ah, cool!
Canonically the greatest wingman of the seven seas.
Yeah, there was the treasure map too!
I was thinking about that earlier because I saw it in our storage.
I was like, oh my gosh, the treasure map.
But yeah, there's still so much.
Maybe if I want to do anymore, I'll touch it in member streams.
But overall, I think that this was a good conclusion we got.
Would you consider this the main ending of Dredge?
The collector just chilled in his place the whole time.
I know!
We did all the work, but we did get the bigger girl.
Oh, it's the bad end.
That's subjective.
There's a good and bad ending, but both are bad endings really.
I see.
Well, this is like a very...
Oh, what's the guy?
Lovecraftian kind of game.
And those stories tend to not have the best of endings.
The other ending is very worth doing.
Cool!
When you remember!
Good old Tino!
Thank you!
Really loved all the Dredge streams.
Have a nice meal and good luck with the meeting.
Thank you, Marilyn!
Me and Toecraftian.
We got a GF, that's a good ending.
Yippee!
Lady!
Any ending involving a lady seems like a win to me.
But yeah, if you wanted to see the other ending, I will probably be doing that in member streams.
And...
Yeah!
Thanks for Dredging with me guys!
This is so fun!
I hope you guys have a good day.
I hope you have a good night.
I hope you have a good rest of whatever time it is for you.
Thank you for the gifted membership!
Thank you!
Thank you for the pig!
I like this ending because...
Because you get to see Cthulhu coming out of the ocean.
Good luck with your meetings.
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
Thanks for Dredging with me.
Thank you!
This is a great journey all things considered.
Enjoy the ravioli.
Thank you!
See you later!
Thank you everyone!
Bye bye!